The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Let's march
ahead into upstate New York
and do formaldehyde.
But first, there's a what
should business do issue
that I should have
brought up last time.
So I'll bring it up
now, because I didn't.
This is super PACs.
How many people know
what the Citizens United
decision is or was?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
well, it's more than that.
Yes, a few.
Let me just walk
through a little bit.
So before 2010, basically,
corporations and unions--
well, they still can't
make direct contributions
to candidates, they could
fund independent organizations
that put up political ads.
But the political ads couldn't
be near elections, et cetera,
et cetera.
Now, after this decision they
can do essentially anything,
as long as it's not
formally part of a campaign.
So if you've been
following this year's
Republican primary
season, there are
a lot of super PAC ads targeting
one candidate or another.
Most of it's negative, and
there's a lot of money.
The question is, you're the
head of a publicly traded
corporation.
You can now make major
political contributions.
The corporation can now make
major political contributions.
Should you?
Should you, or when should you?
Stephen, what do you think.
AUDIENCE: I think they
should be able to.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They're able to.
I'm not talking about that.
Should they?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You're the CEO of--
oh, pick your favorite.
You're the CEO of Apple.
Should you-- and Apple's
got a lot of cash.
Should you spend some
of it to give some of it
to a super PAC which has a
political agenda that you know?
That's all.
AUDIENCE: At the
end of the day, I
think there is no harm in doing
so, because I would recommend
or I would eventually
do that, just
because when we have all these
different candidates that
could potentially move things
in a different direction--
especially for a company like
Apple that relies heavily
on foreign countries to do
some of their manufacturing,
or some of their new products
coming out in other related
patents, it could be
very favorable for them
see a certain type of
political candidate in office
rather than someone else.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you would do it
where the corporation's
interests were
likely to be directly affected.
Any other reason
you might do it?
AUDIENCE: I would also do it--
as could also do it as more
of a publicity type of thing,
where [INAUDIBLE]
[? saying ?] we're
in favor of this green
energy Initiative.
And we would like to see
our candidates support it
in that area.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
OK, David, you with him?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I agree that--
I mean the [INAUDIBLE]
as a CEO, I
would probably donate some money
if there was a direct impact.
But also, again, for PR,
[INAUDIBLE] accomplish
[? as far as the ?]
company in general,
I think Apple gave money to
a political action candidate
opposing the gay marriage
[? act ?] in California.
So that's [INAUDIBLE] part
of [? the ?] initiative
[INAUDIBLE] push forward.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I think that might
have been Apple's regular PAC.
I don't think it was a
super-- maybe I'm wrong.
I think the regular--
the regular PACs,
let me describe it.
They've existed for a long time.
The regular PAC's where the
executives of the company
contribute money.
The super PAC is where the
company contributes money.
There's a big difference.
One is the executive's
own money-- executives
or board members, and
the other is my money
is a shareholder of Apple.
But if it directly affects the
corporation, I take the point.
But you do it for
publicity and you do it
for a variety of causes.
So I'm a right-wing Republican
who owns Apple stock.
Do I like you giving
to a green PAC?
You don't care, OK.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? also ?] [INAUDIBLE]
Apple shares if the [INAUDIBLE]
in the political [INAUDIBLE]
is really that
offensive [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Anybody from the other side
of the room?
Vivian, what do you think?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I [INAUDIBLE].
I don't really know
where we're at.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
The question
is, should a corporation,
let's say Apple, take
a big corporation that has
cash, make contributions--
not the executives.
But should the CEO
cause the company
to make political contributions.
And if so, when?
And if not, why not?
AUDIENCE: Do they make
political contributions?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Should I
go for the Reform America PAC
that favors Ron Paul or the--
I forget what it's called
PAC that favors Romney,
or one of the
Obama-leaning PACs or--
AUDIENCE: I think that's a
really risky position to make
as a [INAUDIBLE] interests
of your shareholders, so--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Shareholders might not all
agree.
AUDIENCE: Right.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Is it in the
interest of the company,
like in regard to Apple with
imports from other countries
in terms of manufacturing.
Like, it's beneficial to the
company and to the shareholders
to maximize value in that way?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
favorable that they're
doing it for the
company's best interests.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So if it's
somebody particularly focused
on them.
Ariana.
AUDIENCE: I agree.
I think that, even if the
company has given donate money
to a cause that you don't
necessarily personally support,
[INAUDIBLE] as a
shareholder, you [INAUDIBLE]
[? their ?]
interests separately.
Like, you have interest in
this corporation as pertains
to making a profit,
and you might also
have separate
personal interests.
And so if personally,
you want to donate
to whoever you think has the
right position on gay marriage,
I think that's fine.
But you should know that the
interest in the corporation
is purely about making a profit.
So if the corporation
is supporting
a cause that furthers that
goal, then that's fine.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But
gay marriage probably
doesn't have a lot to do with
my earnings as a shareholder.
AUDIENCE: So you shouldn't be
worried about the corporation
getting involved in that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Andrew?
AUDIENCE: So one thing
about allowing companies
to do these sorts of things--
I think that whereas
in some situations,
you can see the merit
directly from banks,
and there's this
candidate that I
know it's going to force me to
have higher standards and all
that stuff, I might want to
go for the other candidate.
But I think that having
these sorts of rules allows
for companies to go in
this murky territory,
where you're influencing
things you probably shouldn't.
And you increase your--
in terms of--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, you're
arguing you don't
like the decision.
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
don't like the decision.
You don't like-- but
the decision's there.
AUDIENCE: What I'm trying to say
is that a CEO doing something
supposedly to improve
the company's position
is completely subjective,
because giving money
to candidate x might be
interpreted as I'm doing it
because I want him
to support this,
which is good for my company.
But then there are
whole other things
that you're doing
by doing, which
I think is more of
a negative publicity
than positive
publicity in the sense
that you're influencing
decision-making.
Because it might be
that you're doing it
for him to support action
A. But for action B,
you also have influence on him.
And then that might
be that you don't
want Apple to have
influence on what
he decides on something else.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I've been
on the board of a company that
had one of these ordinary PACs.
And the directors and
the officers chipped in,
and we made contributions.
This was a company
located on Wall Street,
and we were a regulated
company, a securities exchange.
And we made contributions
to both New York senators
and to the congressmen
from Wall Street
so that they'd return our
phone calls basically.
We're not going
to buy influence.
If they're not concerned
about the fate of companies
on Wall Street, then
they're in a lot of trouble.
But to basically
get your phone call
returned, you make a few
thousand dollar contribution.
So that's different
from giving $10 million
to support Newt Gingrich.
So Marie, you had a point,
or were you were waving?
AUDIENCE: No, sorry.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK, Jacob?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a question.
Is it possible for an
international corporation
to contribute to an
American politician--
or like if it's an
American company with, say,
foreign executives
who are making
the decision whether or not
appropriations [INAUDIBLE]
giving money to a politician?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, if
they have a subsidiary that
is a US person.
So if you have a subsidiary
that has a US charter,
then presumably,
that entity can.
You can't make direct
contributions-- well, sorry.
They can't make
direct contributions
to the candidate in any case.
The question is, can you
contribute to a super PAC?
A foreign corporation doesn't
have us rights of free speech.
So I've never heard
it brought up,
but I think it could be barred.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question about
whether it should be done.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
I'd just set up a US company
if I wanted to do that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in
which case could there
be anti-American
interests that influence
[INAUDIBLE] politicians?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yes, so I
actually found an interesting--
there's a foundation
called Sunlight Foundation.
You can find them on the web.
And they looked at who's
making these contributions.
And in fact, you don't find any
publicly held contributions.
I couldn't find any.
Certainly no company
I'd ever heard of
is on the list for contributions
above $25,000. $20,000
actually was their cut.
Lots of private corporations,
individuals, unions,
partnerships.
The only publicly traded
company I could find
is CONSOL, which is a coal
company as far as I can tell.
I don't know them well.
They gave $125,000
to a Romney PAC.
And you have to
ask yourself, why?
I assume that's a
CEO who leans Romney
and whose board is
captive, which is not
unheard of-- that
the board is composed
of his friends or her friends.
I don't know who the CEO is.
So it's interesting that most
large corporations, Apple,
et cetera, are not
playing this game,
even though by law they can.
I just find that interesting.
And it has to do with what
they think their role as CEO is
and how they should behave.
As I said, I could only find
one publicly traded company.
There are a lot of so-and-so
family company contributes,
and that's a family company.
It's effectively a partnership.
So not publicly traded.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Which is?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? already that ?]
maybe all the companies don't
think Romney is going to win,
so nobody's putting in
the money [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: There
is a lot of money going in.
And what we don't see--
if you look at what finances
senatorial and congressional
campaigns, you will see
plain, old, ordinary PACs
contributing, like
the one I described,
where I want to make sure
my phone call gets returned,
and I want you to be sure that
you worry about wheat farmers--
so the wheat
Farmers Association.
But it is interesting,
Obama has a PAC,
but they're not sure
he's going to win either.
So anyway, we'll come back to
the lobbying and contributions.
It's more for access
than for votes I think.
But, OK, yes, Stephen.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick
question for that.
You mentioned that there were
private companies that were
still doing this type of stuff?
Could it be that some
of the public companies
are going through those means
to make their donations?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I think-- and they've
talked about it that there
are some companies that
are dummy companies
that get set up.
But mostly, it hides
rich individuals.
So you can't follow
through from this website.
But if you read
in the paper, they
talk about trying
to track down donors
and getting a post office box.
So it's a company.
It has a post office box.
It's legally incorporated.
Its documents aren't public
because it's closely held.
So that's a mask behind which
some rich person is hiding.
I don't think it would be a sane
thing for a big publicly traded
company to hide that
way, because if there
were enough money,
somebody will find it out.
I mean, there's a lot.
Somebody gives $1 million
and they're hiding,
it's a good story if you
can figure out who it is.
If it turns out to be
Apple, it's a scandal.
So that's too risky.
David?
AUDIENCE: Would it be possible
that some of the larger
companies, whose financial
contributions would
make a significant
impact on the campaign,
are companies that would
already have access anyway?
If Tim Cook called up the
White House and said, look,
we really need to talk to
someone in the treasury
or something, like [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah, Apple
doesn't need to buy access.
This mining company may.
Backing Romney's not the
most obvious way to do it.
So I assume that this is
just a personal preference
of somebody, and a board that
says, yeah, sure it's $125,000.
Who cares?
We'll just cut your bonus.
OK, it's an interesting issue
of the role of the corporation.
But it's also interesting what
most of them choose to do.
Let's go to upstate New
York and do formaldehyde.
I just answered that question,
so we've lost that one.
What's Darren's
issue in the case?
Matthew?
AUDIENCE: He's [INAUDIBLE] part
of [INAUDIBLE] [? opposing ?]
the [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But what
problem is he addressing,
or what opportunities
is he addressing.
What's the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
[? Other ways ?]
to heat their venting.
A lot of steam.
Anything else it does?
Scott?
AUDIENCE: Also, the steam
causes damage to the building,
and it corrodes the
materials in the building.
And it also causes an ice
sheet on the ground, which
is dangerous for employees.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Lovely stuff, lovely stuff.
OK that's what he's got.
He has three options
to deal with these
that he considers first of all.
Do you recall what they are?
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yes.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Lithium
bromide, bromine, yeah.
Anybody got the third one?
[? Wyatt? ?]
AUDIENCE: Everyone [INAUDIBLE]
speed the flow of water
between [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Speed the flow of water
through, so it
just comes out hot,
it doesn't come out of steam.
OK, why is he focused on
combined heat and power?
Why is he focused
on co-generation?
What are the issues with
the others, of the advantage
of this in broad terms?
Kirsten?
AUDIENCE: The disadvantage
for speeding up
the process of producing hot
water was that they didn't
have a good place to put
the hot water, especially
in the summer.
They didn't want to just
dump it into the environment
because that might have
a detrimental effect
on the environment, [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And just
dump it in a cool stream, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so they
said, in the winter,
they could heat the
buildings without using
too much electricity [INAUDIBLE]
going to be a problem.
And [INAUDIBLE] was
that it would require
a lot more [INAUDIBLE] changes.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
OK, so we focused
on combined heat and power.
Did anybody look at this?
If it saves money, does it
save much money relative
to the firm's revenue--
to that plant's revenue?
[? Obedah. ?]
AUDIENCE: In terms of, I
think, power [INAUDIBLE]
cleaning the water or treating
the water, so that they
can make it soft, because it's
usually hard, you save 75%.
But that's only like
$10,000 or $8,000.
But they make millions
upon millions of dollars.
And savings are in the
low hundreds of thousands.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Low
hundreds of thousands, right.
If you calculate--
there's a typo
in the case where it talks about
five days absence being 0.01%.
It's, in fact, 1%.
And if you use
the other numbers,
that plant has an annual
revenue of about $5.1 million
based on the production
numbers they give.
You worked the
numbers, Veronica.
Good.
So what I get is
that the savings
would be maybe 2% of
revenue, the pre-tax savings,
to compare pre-tax to pre-tax.
OK, so not a big deal.
We're going to talk about
whether it's a good deal,
and we're going to talk
about whether they'll do it.
Let me just do a short
riff on combined heat
and power and waste energy.
It's interesting, if
you look at the rejected
energy versus usable
energy by sector--
so this is waste.
Transportation, 75% of what
goes in comes out as waste
energy, electric generation
just about a third,
and every place else about 20%.
And you all know
the answer to that,
what form the waste takes, yes?
Waste energy is
usually heat, yeah.
So, I mean, this one,
transportation's tough,
because cars are not all
that efficient really.
But for public transportation,
this is a tough one.
Residential and commercial,
an awful lot of the energy
is going into
heating and cooling.
You can make it more
efficient of course,
but it's hard to capture.
What's attractive
about industrial
and electricity is
you have high heat.
You have large delta t.
You have the ability to use a
big temperature differential.
And that's the whole
combined heat and power
story, that there really
are two basic forms.
And the case kind
of mentions it.
The first is called
district heating, where
you take waste heat,
relatively low temperature,
from electric generation,
and you pipe it around
to heat buildings.
The Danes did a lot of this.
One of the readings
mentions that.
It's also interesting, the
Soviets did a lot of it.
It requires you to have
power plants relatively close
to offices or
factories or homes,
so it's not the greatest thing.
And of course, it makes more
sense in a cold climate.
Using waste heat to heat
buildings in Arizona
is not necessarily a great deal.
We put in subsidies in 1978--
we'll talk a little bit
about PURPA at some point,
that we're supposed to
encourage district heating.
It didn't do much for a
variety of complicated reasons.
It's generally acknowledged as
a good thing in lots of places,
but we don't do very much
of it in this country
for a variety of reasons.
The other is
electricity generation,
and there are two versions.
The first is basic
combined cycle gas turbine,
which is relatively recent--
I should be able
to date it, but I
can't, maybe the '70s, maybe
the '80s, generation technology.
That's how people are
building efficient gas
plants these days.
You run a combustion turbine
which has a hot exhaust.
You recover the heat
from the hot exhaust,
which makes steam which
drives a steam turbine.
Combined cycle, CC--
so you got two cycles
working and basically
two generation units.
This is pulled off
a Siemens website.
This can be a very
efficient technology.
and it's the same notion
of capturing waste heat.
All you mechanical engineers
more about this than I
do, but others may not.
And this is the proposal.
This is the kind of proposal--
this is pulled from the case.
This is the kind of proposal
that our friend Darren
is considering.
This shows a boiler, but
it has to do, as you know,
with the heat from that
exothermic reaction that
makes formaldehyde.
So this is what
he's considering.
He's considering a simple
system that takes steam
to drive a turbine, generate
electricity for internal use,
maybe for sale.
You cool it down, you recycle,
it you pump it through.
You will have to use
some water, but you'll
pull a lot of the water through.
And the stuff that comes out
will be basically cooling
the condenser.
So this is what he's got.
There are a lot of benefits
of this kind of system
in general terms.
You can reduce energy expenses.
You could worry.
It could avoid the risk
of varying energy prices,
a lot of security, good
environmental benefits--
mom and apple pie.
But the question that Darren
faces is, is it a good deal?
I want to mention two concepts
that the case kind of puts
forward and the spreadsheet puts
forward without defining them.
And I'll talk
about them briefly.
So if you've got a
vector of cash flows CT,
that's the net present value.
You just discount
all the cash flows.
The case talks about
the payback period.
And the payback period
is the smallest time,
such that basically, you get
your initial investment back,
assuming there's an initial
investment up front,
and then returns in
subsequent periods.
You go out as far as you need to
recover the initial investment.
This is a very old-fashioned way
of making investment decisions.
And the problem with
it is stated there,
because it matters what
happens after that time.
I tell you that you
invest $100 today,
you get $50 a year from now.
$50 two years from now, the
payback period is two years.
If that's all, that's
a terrible investment.
You've just given me
your money for two years.
What really matters is, OK,
what happens after that?
What happens after, and the
longer the payback, all else
equal, it may be the
[? worse ?] the investment.
But you can have a really
terrible investment
with a short payback
period because it dies.
So the case talks about it.
I just want to caution
you, by any sort
of reasonable standard,
it's something
you want to look at perhaps,
because it may be a horseback
way of thinking about risk.
After two years, we're
playing with house money,
because we've gotten
our money back.
Andrew, you have a comment.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when I was [INAUDIBLE],,
I assume that even though it's
not the best metric to make
a decision, you could
make a metric to see when
your customers are coming in
terms of if I have something
that has a payback period of
two and a payback period of 15
years, I just know that
I have high risk in terms
of when I get my money
back with the second one.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No,
I think that's right.
But you also want to just look
at the nature of the risks.
If I tell you it's a bond,
then you don't worry about it.
If I tell you it's
a nuclear plant,
OK, the nuclear plant
has a 20 year payback.
But if it runs
for 40 years, it's
got a high net
present value you're
right to say, wait a minute
an awful lot can happen--
see Germany, see Japan.
So maybe I don't
want to do that.
But that's the main argument.
The internal rate of return
is also sort of interesting.
You can think about the net
present value as a polynomial.
Well, it's a polynomial
in 1 over 1 plus r.
And you can say, well, suppose--
we're doing this chalkless?
Suppose that this is
the net present value,
and this is the discount rate.
Then what you might
expect is that if you make
an upfront investment,
you get returns over time,
the higher the discount
rate, the lower
the net present
value, this point
would be the internal
rate of return.
Now, what's
interesting about that
is that when the
picture looks like that,
you don't have to get too
fussy about the discount rate,
as long as it's below r star.
That's what it's good for.
It says, well, I know it's got
a positive net present value
back here.
So if the discount rate's
somewhere in this range,
but I'm not sure
where it is, I know
enough to know the net
present value is positive.
But the graph could
look like that.
It could look like that if
[? at ?] the end of the period,
it is a nuclear reactor, and
we've got to clean it up.
OK, then high discount rates
make that cleanup cost smaller
in present value terms.
It's a polynomial, so the
number of sine changes
is related in ways I've
long since forgotten
to the number of real roots.
If there's only one
sine change, you're only
going to get one real root.
But if you have negative returns
at the end, you can get two.
I suppose you can
get more than two.
The normal thing, and
that's what the slide says,
is to call the
smallest one r star.
I think that's a little weird.
The other thing
to keep in mind--
again, if you just graph these,
you can say here's project A,
here's project B. A has a higher
internal rate of return than B.
But for discount
rates back here, you'd
prefer B if you have to choose.
If you have limited funds, they
have the same upfront cost.
Your discount rate is in here.
B has the higher net present
value, you'd pick it.
So ranking by internal
rate of return
doesn't give you a
desirability measure.
It just gives you some
confidence about--
it allows you to be uncertain
about the discount rate
and still make a judgment
about present value.
OK, questions about those?
David?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? talking about ?]
the payback here, [INAUDIBLE]
value [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No.
Normally, that's how they do it.
[INAUDIBLE]
I don't worry about
interest rates.
Don't give me that fancy stuff.
When do I get my money out?
And you could see the problem.
As I say, I could give you
a one year payback period.
That's a lousy investment.
That's pretty easy.
Give me $100 today, I'll give
it back to you in a year.
One year payback, fabulous.
Not a good idea.
So it's hard to imagine,
but you can read texts
in the '50s that are debating
the merits of payback
versus net present value.
And you say, wait, how?
Anyway, what I want to do--
unless there are questions
about any of this, or general
questions about combined heat
and power, I want to
go to the spreadsheet.
It didn't occur to me to ask,
because of course this is MIT,
but how many of you have
played with Excel before?
Oh, good, that's what I thought.
I feel so much better.
All right, let's go there.
That accords with my priors.
All right, so there we
have the spreadsheet.
Is that readable more
or less in the back?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OK, and let's walk through
a set of questions.
Let's figure out how to walk
through a set of questions.
Hiram, what's happening here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's what you got to do?
Turn the side screen on?
All right.
No.
All right, this
works [INAUDIBLE]..
Thank you.
If you walk through this,
this illustrates my point
about depreciation.
You get total savings, total
expenses, gross margin--
that is to say what does
this thing throw off
in terms of total
savings per year?
You can subtract depreciation
and get earnings before taxes
if you want to.
But then you'll
notice what happens.
They compute taxes and
they add back depreciation.
It appears here and
it appears there.
Depreciation is a game you
and your accountant play
with the tax people.
So when calculating the after
tax in your pocket savings,
you have to say what
depreciation do I get to take.
How does that affect my taxes?
That's it.
If you get faster depreciation,
your income is lower
and your taxes are lower.
Your income being
lower doesn't matter.
Your taxes being lower does.
Is that reasonably
straightforward?
Because you're going to
see this in later life,
I'll guarantee you.
And it shouldn't be mysterious.
It really is-- and it's
an accounting entity.
You report it on taxes.
Some companies use different
depreciation schedules
for taxes than for financial
reporting, which you're
allowed to do to some extent.
OK, question, I talked
before about the difference
between doing
things in real terms
and doing things
in nominal terms.
Assuming this is Darren, not
some Sloan student who wrote up
the case, what's Darren doing?
Is this a real analysis,
a nominal analysis?
Is he confused?
[INAUDIBLE] what do you think?
AUDIENCE: I'm confused.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Huh?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You're confused.
OK, say why.
AUDIENCE: I don't [INAUDIBLE]
understand how [INAUDIBLE]
depreciation [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: On what?
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
how I will characterize it
as either [INAUDIBLE]
[? real ?] or inconsistent.
Like, is this the nominal
what things should be,
or a nominal like interest rate?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, what I
said last time was, if you want
to assume that prices don't
change, in this world,
where prices do change,
then you'd better use a
real discount rate that
measures purchasing power.
If you want to use the kind of
rates you see in the market,
those rates are based
on people's expectations
about inflation.
So you'd better build in
expectations about inflation.
What people often do--
and it's a mistake, is to use
discount rates or interest
rates from the market and
assume prices don't change.
So is he inconsistent like
that, or is he consistent?
I'll give you a hint.
A 10% real rate
would be amazing.
That would be very, very high.
Not amazing, it would be high.
[? Mathoura? ?]
AUDIENCE: [? I mean, ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
doing a nominal analysis
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Doing a nominal analysis,
yeah, because he
builds in-- he has
explicit assumptions
about inflation,
and he's got an interest
rate that's 2003.
That's a market rate in 2003.
No reason you would know that.
But you see the explicit
inflation numbers
at a fairly high interest rate.
So he's doing a
nominal analysis.
It looks consistent.
Is there any defense
in the spreadsheet
or in the case as to the
choice of discount rate?
Sarah?
AUDIENCE: I don't remember
there being a very specific one,
but I'm assuming [INAUDIBLE]
comparable risky assets
on the market.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
He didn't say it, though.
There's no discussion of
where that 10% came from.
After all of that
incomprehensible nonsense
last time about beta,
I was giving you
what you ought to do,
not what people often do.
And clearly, what
he did here was
to take a horseback
reasonable rate.
Let's say at 10%.
That's pretty much in line
with cost of capital you see
and discount rates you see.
You would like him
to have done more.
This is not
necessarily an ideal.
Are the inflation
assumptions reasonable?
Anybody react to those?
What do you think?
2% electricity, 2%
maintenance, 2% chemicals
to be added to the water.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
looking at interest rates
on a yearly basis I don't know.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I'm shocked.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] shocked.
I assumed that's what
people around here did.
I certainly do.
I mean, these are not
implausible numbers.
I mean, if you look
historically at inflation rates,
they run in this country 1% 2
and 1/2% So 2% is reasonable.
What you don't see
in this spreadsheet--
what you might like to see in
life is you might like to see,
well, does the choice
of discount rate matter?
You can check it easily.
Enough we could put
another rate in.
Do the inflation
assumptions matter?
Is the outcome
sensitive to these
things that don't
get defended much?
If you were doing this for
real, and it was your money,
you'd want to do that.
You'd want to say,
OK, I'm not too
sure about those assumptions.
Are they critical?
Do they drive the answer?
If they do, you'd
want to look harder.
We don't see any of that.
We may be missing a dozen
spreadsheets in the background,
but we don't see it here.
OK, as you read the case where
are there risks on this sheet?
Jorge, anything here
that's not certain?
You think it's all
pretty rock solid.
Matthew?
AUDIENCE: I think something
that we didn't really bring up
is that the company [INAUDIBLE]
that the installation time took
much longer, or even a day
longer, [INAUDIBLE] production
would set back the offset
of the cost [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah, we
don't see the lost production
here, and there is
presumably some risk there.
And that's related to the
installation cost for which we
have only an estimate.
We don't have a guarantee.
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: Something that
[INAUDIBLE] jumped out
to me was that I'm assuming
that they did get that grant,
because there's been a lot of
policy talk about getting rid
of them [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, I thought
that was pretty bold
to say, well, I know--
the text says we're
pretty sure we
can get this matching
grant for $172,500.
So we'll just assume we get it.
And there's no lost
production in here.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
during that
time was much more
reasonable [INAUDIBLE]..
I think nowadays it might
be much more difficult
after the financial crisis.
But before then, [INAUDIBLE]
leading up to 2007,
it wasn't very different
for [INAUDIBLE]..
I mean, comparably.
If you-- I think
about [INAUDIBLE]
[? I'm ?] sure that argument
was probably fair for nowadays,
but not necessarily
the case back then.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
If I were a naysayer,
I'd say, do you have
that in writing?
Do you have that grant?
That's big relative to
the whole upfront cost.
And he didn't
quite mention that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Really, I mean,
companies like Tesla
and Fisker Karma got like half
a billion dollar loans for their
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
but this is a New York State--
I don't know this
program, or I certainly
don't know what this
program looked like in 2003.
All I know is that
the case said,
can probably get the grant.
I would say, gee, I'd really
like to know, how does this
look without getting the grant?
I mean, do we know
we're going to get it?
Suppose installation--
in fact the installation
cost, didn't they say $120,000,
$125,000, and he said,
I think we can get
it down to $100,000.
Isn't that right?
Yeah, thank you.
I need support.
So anything else
that's uncertain here
that you might want to focus on?
Julian?
AUDIENCE: I don't
see any removal costs
on there [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Removal costs?
You mean when you
scrap it at the end?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's a good point.
He doesn't talk about it.
He runs it out for--
I forget how long
this spreadsheet runs.
But he didn't talk about what--
presumably, you wouldn't
throw it all away,
since some of it's pipe.
But maybe you would.
I mean, it's a pipe with water,
so it should last pretty well.
But the generator you'd have to
replace, and the turbine you'd
have to replace after a while.
You're right,
there's none of that.
But I guess you
could think about--
well, the question is,
is there a disposal cost?
AUDIENCE: [? Yeah. ?]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
The question isn't would
you have to replace that,
because you probably would.
The question is, should there
be a negative number at the end?
Or could you sell it for scrap?
And he didn't mention
that anything else?
OK, do you like his
treatment of these risks?
Darren is not our
favorite person here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, the
thing is, since we
don't know exactly how he came
up with that discount rate,
then there's a possibility
that he's not really
accounting for the risks
and the cash flows.
I mean, the discount
rate is low.
But maybe he took
that into account
when he calculated the
risk premium associated
with his discount rate.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Maybe, but--
is this my next question?
Yes.
Did he use pessimistic
figures, optimistic figures,
or more or less middle
of the road figures?
Pretty optimistic, yeah.
Chad, you agree, optimistic?
OK, it's an interesting
presentational choice,
because Darren
knows all of this.
And Darren could
just say, well, yeah,
I've been a little optimistic.
But the 10% is high.
This project looks so
good on his numbers
that the better strategy
would be to be pessimistic.
So you could say, look, I
mean, I was very pessimistic,
and it still looked good.
He didn't do that,
or he didn't explore.
Again, if somebody shows you
one of these spreadsheets
in later life, or if when
you're working for McKinsey
they ask you to make
one, for heaven's sakes,
think about the central case.
Think about
variations around it.
He didn't do that.
He took the optimistic case.
Kind of a surprise.
I think what he
should have done is--
oops, let's get it up there.
Yeah, he should have
been central to the road.
Here's a beta question.
So the discounting applies to
how do we value energy savings.
Those energy savings
are going to tend
to be correlated with the
economy, against the economy,
not at all?
The energy savings,
probably two components.
One, what's the
production volume?
And let's take that as fixed
for the moment, because they do.
You tend to run the thing flat
out unless things are terrible.
And the electricity price--
which way is the electricity
price go with the economy?
Brendan.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? doesn't vary ?] much
for the economy.
I'd say that's more
[INAUDIBLE] energy in terms
of gasoline and stuff.
That's more of a-- that varies
a lot more with economy, but--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
There's a lot more.
But if you have
high demand, there's
going to be a supply curve.
Particularly in New York, which
is a market-driven electricity
system, he'll be running
up a supply curve.
So a little bit
with the economy.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I wouldn't say
a very high beta [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No, no, no.
Not a very high beta,
but a positive beta.
Yeah, so maybe-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: But the thing is,
if he was using whatever
that he recovers for
generating more electricity,
then maybe that's the case.
But if is using heat
to sell to people,
then he can say that that's
something that's fairly--
people wouldn't [INAUDIBLE]
[? vary by ?] prices.
But maybe the economy-- people
will need that heat regardless.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But
what's on the table here
is generation.
What's on the table is
generation, not heat.
He doesn't have a scheme
to pipe the heat away.
He has a scheme to use the
steam to run a turbine.
So good point.
It's cold in New York,
even in good years and bad.
But the electricity price
is what's at issue here,
the value of the savings.
So you could argue you should
use a somewhat higher discount
rate than the firms over--
than the cost of capital to
the firm as a whole, just
because there's a positive beta.
We'd have to look at the firm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I have no idea.
Does anybody know anything
about the formaldehyde business?
It's a very diverse group.
No one does formaldehyde at all?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
I don't have a clue.
They wrote the case as if
you just ran the factory.
They didn't talk about
it being cyclical,
and nobody talked about it
none of the naysayers talked
about much cyclicality.
But I don't know.
Brendan?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean,
I think people are still
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
[? Necessary ?] uses,
but it does have other uses,
which the case discussed and I
don't remember.
But OK, what do you think of
the most important assumptions
in this spreadsheet?
Rachel, what do you think?
Tough call, just
staring at it, yes?
You'd have to go and look at--
to answer that question--
and I raise it,
because that is really
the key question.
If I'm a naysayer and he
gives me the spreadsheet,
I say, well what did you check?
How sensitive is this
to the discount rate,
to the electricity price, to
the electricity inflation?
How sensitive is it to
variations in the installation
cost?
Does it matter whether
or not you get the grant?
I can't tell here which
are the key assumptions,
but a little fiddling
with this can.
Alex?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the grant be
the most important assumption
because it's like half of your--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's
half the capital cost.
If you go down, though, to his
net present value, you say,
well, that doesn't matter,
because it's $172,500,
and the net present
value is ginormous.
So lose the grant.
The question is,
what assumptions
would turn it negative?
And he didn't answer that
AUDIENCE: I mean,
if it saved less
than [INAUDIBLE] it would save.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, there
are a lot of things it'll do,
but the question is
which are uncertain?
They describe the technology
as pretty vanilla.
So I assume that was
not-- you're right.
That would do it.
If you saved less [? if ?] the
electricity price collapsed,
if the discount rate
were much higher,
in fact for one
reason or another.
I mean, you could add them up.
I asked this question
not because I
expect you to be
able to answer it,
but because you always
have to ask that question.
What's driving this answer?
Finally, did anybody
see the mistake
in computing net present value?
Sarah.
AUDIENCE: He started in
column C instead of column B.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Bingo.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? compare ?] savings,
as opposed to cost.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
If you go here,
he takes the net
present value of--
it's C45, which is here.
C45, which is the after
tax net cash flow,
that's the right
thing, all the way out.
But he forgot the initial cost.
That's one of the most bizarre
mistakes I've ever seen.
If you look, there's the
formula-- net present value
of all the savings.
Well, what needs to
happen here, it's got to--
not available in protected view.
Do I trust the
contents of the file?
Of course I trust the
contents of the file.
We're all friends here.
What he needs to--
I see, because I erased.
What I need to do here is I need
to subtract the initial cost.
That doesn't turn it
negative, but it did
make a significant difference.
You see what he did.
It's one of these, you say OK.
He took the after
tax net cash flow.
So he went down, added
the savings, added--
that's maintenance savings.
You got savings on electricity,
maintenance, and chemicals,
which gets inflated.
All these get inflated.
You'll see the inflation
rate coming in here,
coming in, coming in.
Adds them up, subtracts
the required maintenance,
gets the net, gets the
gross margin, so to speak,
subtracts depreciation to
get the impact on earnings.
That would be the
increase in earnings.
Gets the taxes, adds back
depreciation, does all that.
Row 45 is the right row.
Net present value, forgot
the initial investment cost.
That's a bad move.
OK, Darren, is not
doing real well here.
Did anybody look at the payback
or the internal rate of return?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I just want go
back to the assumption.
You're also assuming
that, for 10 years,
your production of formaldehyde
is going to stay the same.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: He's
making that assumption.
And we don't know
how sensible it
is, because we don't know much
about the formaldehyde market.
They say that they run
the plant 24 hours a day,
365 days a year, and it's a
highly automated facility.
And he's assuming
that will continue.
It's not clear what other
assumption you ought to make.
But you're right,
that's a key assumption.
If the plant shuts down
or goes to one shift,
those savings figures get cut.
AUDIENCE: I meant the
actual science of it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Huh?
AUDIENCE: I meant
the science-- like,
if your delta e is less
and stuff like that.
Like if you have [INAUDIBLE]
less than [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, you could do it.
I mean, if it's
proportional to throughput--
AUDIENCE: [? In ?] the case,
it specifically states that
the board mainly cares
about [? corruption of ?]
formaldehyde vis a vis
use of electricity.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I'm not sure I get it.
They mainly care
about formaldehyde,
and he's assuming
that we're just
going to keep running it flat
out, because the board cares
about production.
I mean, if the market dies or
if there's a plant problem, that
won't happen, and you just cut
the savings proportionately.
Well, you'd cut the savings
on electricity and chemicals
proportionately.
I'd have to think
about maintenance.
Yeah, OK, internal
rate of return.
How did he do that?
It's ROA, and the
formula is up there.
You could tell it's an
internal rate of return,
because that's what
Excel calls the formula.
And if you look at it, it's--
and 15% is an initial guess.
It's an iterative procedure.
It's B49 to R49, so it's
the internal rate of return
on the pre-tax cash flow.
Why would you do that?
Why wouldn't you take into
account the effective taxes?
If you look at
that, that's weird.
You should do it up
here, and we could do it.
I haven't.
It's going to be significant,
but that's just strange.
That's just strange.
And just for humor,
you really have
to look at the formulas
in a spreadsheet.
He didn't actually compute the
payback per that slide I did.
You didn't actually see when
you get your money back.
He went up here and took the
installed cost, divided it
by the C21 minus C29.
Yeah, divided it by what amounts
to G30 at the C32 divided it
by the annual savings
in the first year.
But the savings
differ year by year,
and he doesn't consider taxes.
So this is a
good-looking spreadsheet.
And what astonished me
when I looked at it was,
wait a minute, that's wrong,
that's wrong, that's wrong.
Otherwise, pretty good.
Any questions about
the spreadsheet?
OK, let's leave this.
No I don't.
Let's go away.
And let's go back.
I just put the spreadsheet
with the formulas in the notes.
Those are the issues
we've talked about.
Now let's talk about--
let's see.
Let's talk about the naysayers.
So I'm guessing--
I haven't spent my life
doing this spreadsheet.
But I'm guessing, if you run
through all of the things
that we've talked about, the
basic assumptions look OK.
The numbers, he's
too optimistic,
but his discount rate's
probably a little high.
So I'm guessing that if
you fiddle and diddle,
you will come to the
conclusion that it does have
a positive net present value.
First objection-- you
are now Darren, folks.
First objection-- if it's
such a great idea, how
come nobody else is doing it?
And your answer is?
Obadiah, what do you say?
You're going to just take that?
You're not going
to just take that.
What's your answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Might be we're smart.
Might be this is a chance to
take a leadership position.
Charlotte.
AUDIENCE: It could be that
the reason they're doing this
is because they do all that
excess heat and steam that's
hurting their plant, and
maybe other people's plants
are designed in a way that they
never had that problem before,
so [INAUDIBLE] considered it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Could
be, although it sounds
like a standard
problem the way they
describe the basic reaction.
You just dump this stuff
in a vat and it gets hot.
Martha?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have the same issue
with ice and [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They might not
have the same issue with ice.
And the ice is
kind of a big deal.
You're right.
If you're in the
middle of the desert
and nobody can see you
venting a lot of steam,
you might just say--
of course, if you're
in the middle of the desert,
you may have a water problem.
[LAUGHS]
Actually, I think
my response would
be this is an opportunity
to show leadership.
But let's try the next one.
What's your answer to that one?
This is what I got, is
I estimated the revenue.
Yeah, yeah, I love
your net present value.
That's just swell.
But there's a risk here.
There's always a risk here.
Yes, there's always a risk.
We talked about outage.
We'll come back to outage.
But, I mean, it's 2% of revenue.
You're going to make the
plant more complicated.
And if you're lucky,
we'll save 2% of revenue.
Why should we do that?
It's going to be
lost in the noise
as production varies, as price
varies, as everything varies.
Why should we
complicate our lives?
Now, these kinds
of things come up.
Sam.
AUDIENCE: Well,
one, you could say
the whole-- you could play
the whole green angle,
like as if it were to make
the environment better.
But also you could say,
like, in the future,
we don't know what's
going to happen
to the price of electricity.
And if it rises, it's a good
insurance policy we have.
And also, you can
say the technology
that we're adding has a
pretty good track record.
Like, it's not that complex.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, I mean, this
is not the first time this
contractor has ever done it.
So the risk doesn't sound
like it's that high.
2% is 2%.
Not bad.
Anybody else?
Ryan.
AUDIENCE: It's actually checking
the formaldehyde process,
so it's not complicating
it in that respect.
But there's also the safety
issue, and like we said,
the green issue, the safety
issue being the [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Got the safety issue.
That's a risk.
Boy, somebody slips
and falls on that ice,
and we get stuck with nice
negligence, big medical bills,
sympathetic plaintiff.
It's really depressing.
Scott.
AUDIENCE: So I think if you look
at it in terms of percentage,
it doesn't sound like very much.
Like saying [INAUDIBLE]
it's only 2%
of our revenue, that doesn't
sound very much at all.
But if you say it's $300,000
we're saving, then while it may
be only a small
portion of revenue,
$300,000 is a large amount of
money to pretty much anyone.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: To
a $5 million operation?
I don't know, maybe.
Yeah, yeah.
It's not trivial
in the absolute.
Anybody else?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: They're also going
to use current employees
to run the same thing.
So I presume their
salary would increase.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I
wouldn't want to presume that.
I'd say their job
satisfaction would
increase because it would make
their jobs more interesting.
That's the pitch I'd use.
And it's a good point.
You might want to see if
you can get them behind it.
You might want to talk it up.
So you could say,
well, I've talked up
with the folks in
the factory, and they
actually like the idea.
[? Emerson? ?]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] having
those same people [INAUDIBLE]
working [INAUDIBLE]
because they're
more familiar with the
[? cost is ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It helps, yeah.
These people know it.
They want to keep
the plant running.
We all want to keep
This actually is common.
I mean, these paraphrase
the objections in the case.
I've added a little bit
of what you always hear.
This is another one.
We can invest and
grow capacity, as
opposed to this
complicating investment,
and we want to
grow the business.
You're not growing the business.
If we didn't have money,
well, then we wouldn't invest.
But if times are good and
we're selling this stuff,
we want to make more of it,
because that's how we grow.
And your investment isn't
a growth investment.
James.
AUDIENCE: Well maybe by selling
electricity and formaldehyde,
you're diversifying
both the [INAUDIBLE],,
which is even safer, even
though [? it's not that much ?]
electricity.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So yeah, we're
reducing the risk of our
operation overall because
of this electricity hedge.
And that means growth is safer.
You might try that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
experience with the technology
that's more PR-friendly,
in the sense that you have
less [INAUDIBLE]
[? gas. ?] [INAUDIBLE]
it's easier to build
things where you
want to get less public outcry.
And so that [INAUDIBLE]
to [INAUDIBLE]
grow that in the future.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, of course, except--
I mean, we are
making formaldehyde.
We can't fake into flowers.
[INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think maybe
finding a better solution
to get rid of the steam could
allow you to increase capacity,
because if it's
just lying around,
there's probably a maximum
amount of formaldehyde
that you can produce and have
this [? thing ?] creating ice.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's
an interesting thought.
So you're saying we could only
do so much of this venting
and ice and so on.
And that may someday
be a constraint on us.
AUDIENCE: Yes, in finding
a better solution,
that maybe [INAUDIBLE] enable
them to expand it even more.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
OK, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: So this process
saving money every year
can add [INAUDIBLE] to that
year investment [INAUDIBLE]
get your initial investment
back [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Roughly year 3, yeah.
Extra money.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
actually [INAUDIBLE]
capacity every year after that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, that's nice.
That's nice if we play it right.
I mean, you get this stuff.
You're getting this.
They don't specify in the
case who he's talking to.
But presumably, this is
a middle management group
that passes on capital
spending requests.
So your response would be,
look, folks, if this plant is
more profitable--
which it will be,
we're going to be
able to use that to get more
investment money to expand.
We don't necessarily get
to put it in our pocket
because it's all part
of the corporation,
but it would be a
good justification.
Andrew.
AUDIENCE: What you could
be doing with the--
that's kind of a question.
What you going be
doing with the money
you're using to build
this, [INAUDIBLE]
by your discount
rate essentially.
So we can just argue that--
I mean because it's kind
of an opportunity cost
that they're mentioning, right?
I mean, instead of spending
the money to do this,
you can spend to
grow the business.
But then you can answer,
like, that's why I'm using--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It is,
except in most companies
of any size, you basically do
a capital budgeting process.
We're going to invest x--
I mean, you
shouldn't, but you do.
We're going to
invest x this year.
Your job is to figure out
how best to invest it,
as opposed to saying anything
that has a positive net
present value, we'll
figure out how to fund it.
And if you a great project--
and this is a way of just doing
a regular systematic budgeting
process.
If you come up with a
great, big, big project,
then you go to top
management and you say,
I know this is over the
capital budget, but.
But for little things like
this, and for this company,
this is probably a
relatively small project.
Darren doesn't have the
discretion to do it himself.
Routine things, he
probably has a limit.
You have a spending limit
without approval of $20,000
maybe, maybe more.
For anything above that,
up to some ceiling,
you got to clear it with
whatever this group is
that is full of skeptics.
Beyond that, the group has to
go and say to top management,
I know you only gave us $800,000
for the formaldehyde division.
But we have this great idea,
and we'd like to present it.
So it economizes is on top
management time to some extent.
It also gives you an
orderly budgeting process,
so you can predict cash flows.
But it imposes this
kind of constraint.
I mean, capital
budgeting processes do.
At some point, somebody
sits in the room--
you've got a good project,
I got a good project.
We don't have money for both.
And they're not so good that
we can get money for both.
We need to choose.
And there is a tendency
to say we want to grow.
We want to grow.
That is an issue that
investments in efficiency
and conservation
traditionally face
because they're not
growth investments,
and people like growth.
[? Obeida? ?]
AUDIENCE: I also
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned
this about the second
point, but it might
be 2% of revenue for one plant.
But what if you
have several plants?
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: If
it's like this plant,
it's 2% of revenue
for all plants, right.
AUDIENCE: If you install the
system at a number of plants,
you could easily
end up with revenue
like savings in the millions.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You could
end up with a good number.
It would still be 2% of
revenue probably on that order.
OK, yeah.
Another way to do
that argument--
and it's a little variation on
the first one, would be, look,
guys, we can lead the
way for the company,
whatever this group is
that's approving the budget.
If this works here, and we're
very confident it works,
we're going to get a lot
of points with the company,
because we led the way
to 2% of revenue savings
in all of our
formaldehyde operations.
Or maybe it's not 2% everywhere.
We've got to run the numbers.
Electricity is
probably particularly
expensive in upstate New York.
It would be cheaper in Ohio.
But that's where
I'd go with that.
I wouldn't say 2% is--
2% is big if I multiply
it by a large number.
I would say it's
in our interest,
as the group sitting
around the table,
to demonstrate to the guys
up above that we can do this.
OK, here's another one.
This is a killer.
Our bonuses depend
on production.
That's how we do it.
And you're telling me it's
five days of downtime,
and we can recover from it.
But we don't know we
can recover from it.
You're putting my trip
to the Caribbean at risk,
and it's very cold in upstate
New York in the winter.
I need that bonus.
This is a risk.
What's your response, Casey?
You look ready.
You are ready on
this one, am I right?
AUDIENCE: Well,
first, they might
be able to switch their
production schedule to account
for take those
five days off then,
because they're not running
at full capacity all the time
anyway.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
The case leads you
to some optimism, yes.
AUDIENCE: And then,
additionally, you
can just go back to the
[? handy ?] argument
that businesses need
to produce money,
but they don't necessarily
need to maximize their funding.
So we can do this [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
But this last point
isn't about the business.
It's about my trip
to the Caribbean.
[LAUGHS]
And I care about that.
This one's tough.
I don't mean to put you
particularly on the spot,
but this one's tough.
If you've got the compensation
structure set in such a way
that it biases toward
growth and towards revenue,
this is a tough one.
Charlotte?
AUDIENCE: You can--
back to the point
that we made on the
last objection, where
if you're the first plant to
start [INAUDIBLE] something
that saves your
company 2% in revenue,
and adds other plants then
the heads of organization
will look favorably on
you, and [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: We
can get a bigger bonus
if we can sell this.
Tough argument.
It's one you'd try, though.
David.
AUDIENCE: You would
get a promotion
if you can
demonstrate initiative
among your scale of thinking.
Because if you don't do it,
and someone else implements it,
they might displace
you [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It works for Darren.
It might not work for the
guys one notch above Darren.
It might, though.
It might.
Look, if you guys
all get behind this,
we'll all ride up
the ladder together.
Martha.
AUDIENCE: Going back to
what was said about how,
after your investment
was returned,
you'll be continuing
to save money.
So your close may
be less this year,
but they do much
greater in future years,
while they're able to start
expanding that growth,
and we're able to start--
so maybe instead of going
to the Caribbean this year,
you go to Vale or something.
[LAUGHTER]
But five years down the road,
you can go to Jurassic Park.
I don't know.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Hey,
ski in the Adirondacks
instead of skiing in Vermont.
I don't know.
OK, anybody else?
OK.
How about that?
The case talks about
all these policies.
There's this killswitch problem.
There are other policies
about interconnection.
They're still in flux.
Maybe what we ought to
do-- it's a good idea.
OK, you've sold me.
It's a good idea.
Why don't we just wait?
Let's just let
this stuff settle.
Maybe if we do it
now, we'll have
to take precautions
we wouldn't have
to take if they apply more
sensible policies down
the road.
David.
AUDIENCE: You could argue
none of the competitors
are doing it now,
so doing it now
gives us a competitive
advantage versus in the future,
competitors are
already [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But we are.
But suppose the policy
goes against us.
Suppose instead of
making it easier
to interconnect that the
policy change makes it harder.
It requires us to put on
more protective devices--
let's say $200,000 worth.
And then, all of a sudden--
that's extreme.
But all of a sudden, the
policies we were counting on,
the ability to
sell excess power,
which is still in
flux at this point,
it turns out we can't sell it.
Turns out we need to
have more protection.
Maybe we should wait.
Claudia, what do you say?
You sold up with the skeptics?
I mean, that's
not a crazy point.
No.
AUDIENCE: If it tends to
approach local regulators
directly and [INAUDIBLE]
make a point of [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, one
thing Darren might have done
is he might have not
necessarily approached them.
But he might try to
get a feel from, say,
his local representative.
A lot of this stuff is
going on at the state level.
He's running a
pretty big operation.
He's one of the
great polluters-- no,
one of the great
operations in the area.
He might make a phone
call and say, look,
can you tell me where
this stuff stands?
I mean, is it going to get
resolved in six months,
or is this a five-year
marathon and it'll
get changed every so often.
That matters.
If it's going to get resolved
in six months, let's wait.
If it's going to be debated for
the next 10 years, why wait?
Ariana.
AUDIENCE: I think
this is where it
would have come in useful
for him to have made
a more pessimistic analysis.
And so maybe you do that first.
And then you say,
like, OK, well--
because, I mean,
when we looked at it,
it looked like, even if
some of the estimates
were a little bit
more pessimistic,
or you couldn't get the
grant that you wanted maybe,
or you estimated it with
some of the policies
not falling your way.
And you could still-- maybe the
profit wouldn't be as large.
But in the long run,
it's still worth it.
And you could come
and say like, look,
this is what I think
is going to happen.
I mean, you never really know.
And even if it goes
a little bit sour,
like we still are making
some kind of profit.
So it's worth it anyway.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK,
let me go to one last one.
Who'd like to make
the elevator pitch?
Is there a spin he
can put on this.
So he walked in with
his spreadsheet.
He got all these arguments, all
these nay-saying nitpickers.
What do you stand up and say?
Caroline, are you ready
with an elevator pitch here?
You ready with a
one minute speech
to make the committee turn
around and charge out the door
and go to the CEO and do it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Not quite ready, OK.
Anybody?
[? Albina, ?]
you're ready today?
AUDIENCE: OK.
that's good.
Sorry to disappoint you.
I don't have an elevator
pitch, but I'm curious as
to what the outcome was of
this case, because it's not
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Let
me fish one more time
for an elevator pitch.
And then I'll tell you what I
think happened, which is not
unrelated to that question.
Max?
AUDIENCE: You want to appeal
to the interests of the board,
and their interest is
always the production
and maximizing profits.
So emphasizing the fact that
this short-term investment will
save a lot of money in the
long run, which you can in turn
invest in greater production
in the future, which
will give them bigger bonuses.
You can also appeal, I think--
it deals with a couple of points
to the safety of the workers
and to the integrity
of the whole plant.
In the article, it
talked about the ice
being a hazard for the
workers and the corrosion
of some of the structure of the
building [INAUDIBLE] as well.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
What I think happened,
and it's not unrelated, to that
my understanding-- and I've
tried to verify it and I'll
see if I can do it next time,
is that in fact,
when he presented it
to the review operation,
it was turned down
for all of those reasons.
And he managed to get the ear,
one way or another, of the CEO,
and he pitched it as
industry leadership,
green public relations.
Economics are OK.
Economics are pretty
good, so we're not
going to lose money
on this investment.
But moreover, think about what
we can say to the community.
Think about what we
can say to the workers.
Think about what you can say
at the next industry convention
when you stand up and give
your leadership speech.
We'll get benefits.
I mean, we're venting steam.
It's not hurting anybody,
but it doesn't look good.
It's got to look better.
So he went around these
guys, is my understanding,
and pitched it as
an opportunity--
and not just an
economic opportunity.
He overstated the economics.
The economics are OK.
But he pitched it
as an opportunity.
And we'll see next week, and
we will see after the vacation,
that whether you view something
as a threat or an opportunity
makes a lot of difference
as to how you act on it.
Thank you very much.